[APPLAUSE]
MURAD AWAWDEH: Good afternoon.
My name is Murad Awawdeh.
I'm the director of political
engagement at the New York
Immigration Coalition.
You're probably like, what
is the New York Immigration
Coalition?
Well, we're a coalition
of over 200 organizations
across the state of New York.
We have a member organization
in every single county
of this state.
The NYIC-- short for the New
York Immigration Coalition--
fights for immigrant rights
and immigrant justice
in the state of New York
and across the nation.
We're an umbrella policy
and advocacy organization
that works with our
memberships to activate
their bases to ensure
that we are fighting
for the rights of all immigrants
and refugees in New York.
I'm going to speak to you
guys a little bit about what
brought me to this work.
When I was 10 years old, I
was growing up in a community
called Sunset Park.
And that's located in
southwest Brooklyn.
My whole family had asthma.
And that, at the time, seemed
like something that was common.
But it was common to only
people in the community who
also had asthma.
My sister, almost
every single day,
would have a vicious
asthma attack
and end up waiting on the
floor for an ambulance
to come to take her to the ER.
And that really spoke to me
in a way where it was like,
come to think of it,
no one in my family
who lives elsewhere
has to deal with this.
So I started to look
around my community
and realized that
my community wasn't
identical to the communities
to the sides of it--
Park Slope on one side,
Bay Ridge on the other.
I noticed that we had no trees.
I noticed that we had
an enormous amount
of trucks on our streets.
I noticed that we had a highway
and multiple power plants.
And shortly after realizing that
there was something inherently
wrong with the living
environment we were currently
in, a group of young
people started organizing.
And they started organizing
for environmental justice.
And that didn't start
off as like, yeah, we're
going to fight for
environmental justice.
It started off as like, why
don't we have clean air?
Why don't we have clean
air in a community
that's low-income,
majority immigrant,
and we're all facing
the same issues?
So shortly after that, we really
started to educate each other
on what was happening.
A couple of nonprofit
organizations
started to provide
us with support.
And young people
started to organize.
And the power of organizing
really was a testament within
my childhood and seeing that
people power was real and that
it wasn't just something
that you can't--
I'm a huge math fan.
And sometimes the data doesn't
match up to things that happen.
And as the tech
community and folks
who are reliant on data and
coding and everything else that
really doesn't have a
human impact at times,
it's not measurable.
It's not quantifiable.
So to folks in Google and
to folks within the tech
community, I think
sometimes we look
at how the people perspective
actually really does move
forward in a way which is
not definable by numbers.
And shortly after, a group of
young people that started off
about 15 to 25 young
people defeated
a multibillion-dollar
power plant.
Thereafter, they planned a
park on top of a Superfund site
and then fought to get money
from the state to clean up
that Superfund site.
And then it wasn't
just fighting against,
but fighting for-- changing
the landscape of what
the community looked like.
And that's my beginning to
how I got into advocacy.
And I was invited to speak
today at Google to talk
about how civic engagement--
and to me, civic
engagement is organizing--
how you can organize
and participate
civically to ensure that we are
moving in the right direction
to protect our communities
from the uncertain times
that we live in.
And those uncertain times
began on November 8, 2016,
when our current
president was elected.
And we believed that
everything he said
was going to be literal.
We didn't think that he was
just speaking to his masses
to get them riled
up to vote for him.
We figured he was
going to do what
he said he was going to do.
Shortly after, it happened.
Shortly after taking
office, Donald Trump
signed a number of
different executive orders.
The first was to double the size
of Customs and Border Patrol.
The same executive
order was also
intended to triple immigration
enforcement officers
and build the most inexpensive
and wasteful wall ever.
And when we saw that coming
down the pike, we were like, OK,
well, what we've seen in years
prior-- this was before him--
is that pretty much
Customs and Border Patrol--
which we, as New
Yorkers, really don't
interface with unless
we're flying into JFK
and we see them at the airport--
but we tend to
forget that we have
a northern border at
the top of New York that
is shared with Canada.
Border Patrol can
operate 100 miles
within the radius of
the wall, of the border.
And what that means
is-- and any water.
So we have the ocean,
we have rivers.
Pretty much, the entire
state of New York
is covered that CBP can
come in and operate under.
And what they do
is, pretty much,
they have an enormous
amount of power.
So if you are driving
from Canada into New York
and you want to go
back home after going
to Montreal or Ontario,
you have to stop,
and they can check you.
And what tends to happen is that
folks who are brown or black
tend to get stopped
more than others.
Specifically, Muslim
folks tend to get stopped
and cautioned at a
higher rate than others.
And as an
Arab-American Muslim, I
think that the reality that
we were in at that point when
this executive
order was issued was
that our communities--
and this is
the broad sense
of "communities,"
immigrant
communities-- are going
to be faced with an enormous
amount of challenges moving
forward.
Shortly after that
executive order was passed,
there were rumors of the Muslim
ban dropping sometime soon.
We had heard that it was
going to happen the same day.
The next day, we heard it
was going to happen that day.
And then finally, about
three days later, again, we
took him by his word, and
he came through on it.
So on January 26
at about 4:42 PM,
Donald Trump signed
an executive order
banning people from seven
Muslim-majority countries
from entering the United States.
And what you may have seen may
have seemed beautiful chaos
that came out of it.
And people felt in their
hearts that it was wrong,
and they came out
to the airport.
And the New York
Immigration Coalition
was at the forefront of that.
We knew it was
coming down the pike.
And we knew that he
was going to fulfill
his promise to his base.
So we wanted to ensure that
whatever was happening,
that we were going to
ensure that the most
impacted voices were going
to be at the front lines
and make sure that
folks who are impacted
have some sort of defense.
And that defense was
done by lawyers--
precisely, over 1,000 lawyers
who showed up to JFK for free
and fought for the
release of everyone who
was detained at the airport.
Couple that with the enormous
outpouring of support
that we had from people
coming out to protest,
the numbers went up as high
as 10,000 people showing up
that day.
And it was honestly
quite beautiful to see.
In the morning when we got
there at around 8 o'clock
in the morning,
there was 10 of us.
Shortly after, it was about 25.
We did a call to
action on social media.
And then media showed up.
And then it went from
two dozen to over 10,000,
to the point where
the entire parking
lot in terminal 4, the parking
garage, the passenger pick-up
area was filled to
the brim with people
demanding that those who had
been detained to be released.
Later that evening,
Judge Donnelly
in the Eastern
District Court finally
issued a temporary
injunction on the Muslim ban,
which was quite remarkable.
Later that evening, we
planned to have a march
to ensure that New
York's voice was actually
being heard across the nation,
demanding that this ban is not
going to stand.
And what we did was we
held a march and rally
that started at Battery
Park, overlooking
the Statue of Liberty.
And we thought
originally we were
going to have about a couple
of thousand people coming out,
because a lot of folks
went out the night before.
But we were amazed that over
30,000 people showed up.
And the reality is, is
that there is a cause
and effect to everything.
And what we've been
seeing is that,
as people are becoming more
civically engaged in ensuring
that their beliefs are not
being challenged in a way
where you don't feel as
if we are honoring what
our country was founded to
do, that folks are really
taking a stand now.
And the stand isn't
just, I'm going
to send out a quick
Tweet, which is amazing,
or I'm going to put a Facebook
post up, which is great,
but showing up and showing
up when it matters.
The next thing that our
federal government has done
is issued an attack
on sanctuary cities
and threatened to de-fund
cities through the Department
of Justice.
And what does that mean?
What are sanctuary cities?
Are sanctuary cities
these lawless cities
where people are
moving forward in life
and doing whatever they
want with no accountability?
No.
Sanctuary cities means
that cities are not
going to participate and assist
in federal law enforcement
agencies' attempt to detain
people, which is not illegal.
It is pretty much
the Fourth Amendment.
And I think that when
people think about it,
they're like, well,
it may seem odd.
But it's not.
New York City became
a sanctuary city
under not the very
liberal mayor that we
have now, Mayor de Blasio--
not our centrist
former mayor, who
was Mike Bloomberg, who
was pretty pro-immigrant.
It happened under
Rudy Giuliani--
the same man who is Donald
Trump's adviser right now.
So the reason why he did
it was because he wanted
to ensure that
everyone in the city
was able to feel comfortable
enough to go to law enforcement
if something happened--
was comfortable enough
to go to the hospital
if they were sick--
was comfortable enough to ensure
that their kids went to school.
And I think the reality is, is
that the rhetoric that we're
hearing now is,
quite frankly, bull.
So when we're talking
about, how do we
ensure that our
communities are safe,
sanctuary cities are
not harboring people
who are doing anything illegal.
Sanctuary cities are ensuring
that everyone has their rights.
I think that that's
what it comes down to.
So to go back to what else
is happening nationally,
everything that you hear tends
to be that we're law and order,
we're going to ensure that
everyone who's here is fine,
anyone with status
is OK, we're only
going after the criminal aliens.
And that rhetoric is actually
really dangerous, because who
is defined as a criminal alien?
For instance, green
card holders--
these are folks who are legally
permanent residents, who
may or may not have had
a run-in or two with law
enforcement on very
low, minor offenses,
and now they are on
track for removal.
You also have,
just two weeks ago,
it was announced that a young
person who had received DACA--
which is Deferred Action
for Childhood Arrivals--
in California actually was
detained and then deported
within three hours.
DACA is intended to protect
people from deportation.
The United States government
told these young people
who received DACA,
sign up for DACA.
You will get work authorization,
you will get a Social Security
card number, you
will get everything
you need without
status, but we will not
focus on you to deport you.
And obviously, in this
current administration,
that is not true.
What else are we
seeing nationally?
We're seeing that enforcement
of immigration enforcement
is happening at a
much higher rate.
And you're seeing that there
is retribution for people who
are speaking out against this.
So in cities in Texas
that are sanctuary cities,
there has been a higher rate
of raids happening there.
There has been higher
enforcement in other cities
that are technically
sanctuary cities.
And what we're seeing is that
it's a very vindictive way
of getting back at folks.
They try to teach
people a lesson.
And that's not the country
that we have ever been.
We have a very interesting past.
And I think that the future
that we all intended to have
is not the one that we're
on track for right now.
So what is the New York
Immigration Coalition doing?
We're working at
the federal level
to fight back as hard as we
can against these policies
that Donald Trump is
introducing and signing.
We're also ensuring
that, at the local level
in our state, that we're
putting together policies that
will harden our state
from these policies
so that when folks are
trying to access documents
from the state on
who has Medicaid
or who went to this hospital
or who went to that hospital,
that there are policies
put in place for that.
Recently, we just had a
pretty significant win
where we worked with
the city and the state
to ensure that ICE isn't
allowed in schools.
To even think that that was
allowed before where children--
kindergarten to 12th grade--
are in school and ICE can
walk in, pick up a kid,
is beyond me.
We're working on
ensuring that immigrants
from across the state have
access to legal services.
There are studies that show
that if an immigrant is
undocumented, with
documentation, or anything
and has legal representation
during immigration proceedings,
there's a higher rate of
them being able to stay.
We're helping those with
status become citizens.
There's been a very
long period of time
where folks who have green
cards are like, I don't really
need citizenship, because I
have my green card, I'm fine.
What we've realized is that
that's not necessarily true.
So we're trying to
ensure that folks
who are eligible to become
citizens do become citizens.
And the other thing that
we're doing right now
is fighting harder than
we've ever fought before
to ensure that services for
immigration are in place
and funded for our newcomers.
And what do I mean by that?
Across the state and
across the nation,
there's always been this fight
for adult literacy education
funding.
And what does that mean?
That funding would
specifically go out
to educate folks on how to learn
how to read and write English.
And for being a
country that everyone
loves that folks want to speak
English, we don't fund it.
We also don't fund
the ability for people
to get health care or
health care services.
So we want to ensure that we
can expand the pool of who's
eligible to get insurance.
We want to ensure that folks
who may have had a run-in that
was a low offense see a lawyer.
And that's not a big ask.
And then looking at how
we move the pendulum
and looking at how we actually
start discussing these issues,
and we look at the
tech community.
A lot of these tech companies
were founded and created
by immigrants.
A lot of folks think
that tech just happened.
It doesn't just happen.
There are people behind it.
And I think that
the reality is, is
that we have gotten comfortable
being who we are as just
a person, not realizing where we
came from or where we're going.
And in that, we have to
start challenging ourselves
to be more vocal
about, where are we now
and how are our communities--
our larger communities,
our tech community,
which will be impacted,
our home community-- how
will that be impacted?
And the generations to come,
how will they be impacted?
And what is your
role in doing this?
And what is your role to
ensure that we're actually
pushing the pendulum
towards justice and not
towards injustice?
So what can you do?
And I think that that has
been the new big question
of the day.
Everyone asks, what can I do?
I want to do something,
but I don't really
feel comfortable
speaking publicly,
or I don't feel comfortable
going and writing an op-ed
or speaking to my
elected official.
There's a number of
things folks can do.
And the most
important is speaking
to your elected official--
your federal officials,
your state officials,
and your local officials.
First, you should
know who they are.
Second, you should
call them often
with your opinions
and your concerns.
They do take phone calls,
emails, and letters, or even
a visit, very seriously.
So if they're hearing from you
and they're hearing that you're
concerned about the
immigration policies
or you're concerned about
the restriction on H-1B visas
your colleague's safety,
that will go a long way.
One thing that
folks tend to forget
is that we almost have an
election every single year.
So last year was the
federal elections.
This year we have city and
municipal, local, regional
elections.
And one thing people think is
that, my vote doesn't really
count.
And then they point
to Electoral College.
Sometimes I'm like,
OK, well, there
may be some true
criticism there.
But your vote does count.
You count, and it's
an entire process.
You count.
And the reality is, is that the
most important elections are
the local ones.
And people tend to forget that.
If you live in New York City,
you have city council races,
you have the mayor's race, you
have the public advocates race,
the city comptroller.
If you live in other
parts of the state,
you have your county executive
and your local legislator
races.
And across the nation,
you have other races
happening this year.
There are a ton of special
elections happening
to fill vacancies for
congressional members, which
you will see in South Carolina,
which you have seen in Georgia,
and which you have seen in,
I believe it was Kansas.
So vote.
If there is one thing
you can do and you just
want to have that one thing
be it, your vote matters.
And your vote matters more
than you actually think.
There's races that have been
won by 17 votes in this state--
17.
It's like that last row.
That last row
decided an election.
Voting is critical, more so
today than it ever was before.
Organize.
Organize a community town hall.
Know who your neighbors are.
A lot of folks--
and I think that this goes
across the board and not
just in the tech community
or the advocacy community--
but in general, the
vast majority of people
do not know who their neighbors
are more than "hello,"
"good morning," "good
night," "great seeing you,"
and that is it.
Know who your neighbors are.
Speak to your neighbors.
See what their issues are,
what their concerns are.
And then organize together.
Bring together the
rest of your community
to have a town hall or
a community meeting.
Hold it in your lobby
at your building.
Hold it in front of your house.
Hold it at a library--
anywhere.
Organize, get to know
each other, fight
for a shared vision.
That is the only way we
can move forward here.
Mobilize.
Mobilizing yourself plus family
and friends, or colleagues,
is going to be critical.
There has been a protest or
a rally or a march literally
almost every single week.
How many have you been to?
Right?
Go to one.
Make that a task of the day.
Just go to see what
the rally is about.
Who's doing what?
Why are people here?
Ask folks, what really
brought you out today?
Get yourself out.
Get out of your comfort zone.
Mobilize.
This is what is
going to be and what
has been the only way to
actually create change
under this administration.
You saw that with the
American Affordable Care Act.
You saw that with
the Muslim ban.
You're going to see that
with everything else that's
coming down the pike.
So there's going to be a budget
extender at the federal level.
You should look through it,
see what's going to be included
and what's not, and
then really ensure
that you believe that
your tax dollars are
going to the right places.
Mobilize.
Educate-- seek out information
from valid sources.
I can't emphasize
this any more than I
have in the past couple of
months where people are sending
me articles of
things that I said,
which are not things
that I've said.
I'm like, where
did you hear this?
There should be a video of it.
Look at the video and then look
at the entire clip, not just
two words of what I've said.
I think research and education
is extremely important.
And I think that
we're on a pathway
that alternative facts
have become normalized.
And I think that we just
have to call it what it is.
And they're all lies.
So how can you ensure
that you are educating
yourself and your community?
Research and educate.
Share the information
that you have
found with your colleagues.
Share it with your family.
Share it with your friends.
I think educating
yourself and your friends
is really important.
There are issues that
I'm continuously learning
about within immigration.
And I think that
that's something
that is upon us all to really do
and to really look into things
that are going to
impact ourselves
and our families
and our community.
Volunteer.
You all have an
acquired set of skills.
Use it for good.
Look at a nonprofit that you
really want to volunteer with.
Say, this is what I can do, let
me know if you're interested,
if not, I'll just show up
to whatever you're doing.
More than likely, they
will respond to you
and say, thank you,
we would love for you
to work on this with us.
Nonprofits across the
state and the nation right
now are not really equipped
to respond to the level
that they have been
responding right now.
So any assistance in
volunteering your time or not
is going to be really
important for them
to be able to become successful
and even more successful
and continue to fight, because
that's what it comes down to.
Because in every
victory, there's
10 losses before that you
probably don't even know about.
So you just need to ensure
that you're providing yourself
and that you're making yourself
available to these folks.
Donate.
I think that you hear
this all the time.
One standard that I like--
not that I'm bragging,
because we are--
is that we're a
Google-approved nonprofit.
And your donation will
be matched by Google.
So look through-- if you want to
donate to New York Immigration
Coalition, go for it.
You should.
If not, look for
another nonprofit that's
doing great work
in your community
that you want to support.
And then last but not
least is stay connected.
A lot of things happen at a
very rapid pace these days.
And social media has become
a really amazing tool
to ensure that we are
continuously following up
with each other and making sure
that we know what's happening
and that we're getting
out the right information
in the quickest way possible.
So follow us on Twitter.
Follow us on Facebook.
Make sure that you text our
action alert network, which
is right there.
Text NYC to 86-42-37.
That's the right number, yes.
And stay connected.
And I can't emphasize
that more than anything.
I think if you walk away
from here doing one thing
and texting that number is it,
I think that that is, in itself,
you're on the right
track to starting
to become civically
engaged in a way
that you haven't been before.
And showing up,
because showing up
is probably one of the most
important pieces of this.
So with that, I will
take any questions.
I want to thank Google
for having me here today.
I think there's microphones
on either side of the stage.
There's one there and one here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for coming.
I just had a question
about strategies
for talking to
people who disagree,
because I think especially
at a place like Google,
you don't find that many people
who disagree with these things.
And I've also been hearing a lot
about how arguing with people
doesn't really
change anyone's mind.
It just makes everyone
more firmly committed
to what they already believe.
So what have you found
that's effective for having
constructive conversations with
people who disagree with you?
MURAD AWAWDEH: That's
a funny question.
I actually had an off-the-record
debate with someone
last week who is completely
against every single viewpoint
and belief that I have.
And it was interesting, because
I prepared for three days
to ensure that I can
counter every claim she
has with actual facts.
And I was like, that's really
not going to work here.
So honestly, I heard her out.
And I listened to
everything she said.
And I took notes.
And I was like, OK,
thank you for letting
me know how you feel.
Now this is what you said,
this is how I heard it,
and this is what
the actual truth is.
And we didn't agree
on 100% of everything
I had mentioned to her.
But from that conversation--
I never expected this--
we agreed on five points.
And I was literally floored
by her saying, yeah, of course
I agree with that.
One was that everyone
deserves to live
with dignity and respect.
The other was that
there is consequences
to people's actions,
but there shouldn't
be a double punishment
for anything.
And that, in itself,
was a huge deal,
because she's an enormous
anti-immigrant fanatic.
And I'm like, whoa, you
just agreed with something
that you've been going
out and really cheering
your crowds with.
Making sure that folks have
the right to live not in fear
and making sure that
people who do come here
have opportunity and
pathway for citizenship.
And while we didn't
agree on 100 things,
we agreed on those five
really critical pillars
that I think allowed
us to continue
to have the conversation.
You're not going to change
anyone's mind in a day.
their mind in a week or a month.
It takes time.
And I think that folks who
have their set of beliefs
have believed that
for a very long time.
So unless they are exposed and
working alongside or hearing
from other folks and
educating themselves
on the alternative
opinion and not something
that they're reading
on a fake news site,
I think that that is what's
going to change people's hearts
and minds.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I've heard one of the things the
Trump administration has said
is that they're going to punish
sanctuary cities by cutting off
the federal funds.
I was just wondering
if you know if there's
any strategies being
discussed about that,
because it's sort of insane.
Because last I heard, we send
about $1.20 for every dollar we
get from the government.
MURAD AWAWDEH: Yeah.
Not too familiar with that--
I just know that we do
have an internal strategy.
But our strategy right now is--
what we know is that they
kind of can't do that.
And if they haven't,
they will be
sued by a couple
different states,
because what they're
doing is actually
discriminatory in practice.
And if you heard of our
Attorney General Sessions
last week's speech saying that
New York City is lawless and is
the most dangerous
it's ever been,
because being a sanctuary
city, last week,
and you heard the response from
the NYPD, which pretty much can
be its own military
force, really
saying that if it weren't
for being a sanctuary city,
we would be extremely dangerous.
And because we are
a sanctuary city,
we have the lowest
crime rates ever.
I feel like that
side has spoken.
Anyone on this side?
No pressure.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I'm an immigrant, but I've
spent my whole adult life here.
But even so, it feels
strange to tell people
that were born and
raised here, this
is how you should
run your society
to benefit me, even though,
if I believe in a cosmopolitan
world and all of that.
Do you have any advice?
Because it feels weird,
because it feels like you're
just being a rude house guest.
MURAD AWAWDEH: Yeah.
That's a good point.
I think it's more so about
talking about your own story.
And that's why I
started off with mine.
And I think that folks
tend to forget that we all
came here from somewhere.
It might not have been your
parents, your grandparents,
or even your great-grandparents.
But we all came here.
None of us are
indigenous to this land,
unless we're Native American.
So my personal story really does
resonate with a lot of people.
I didn't start off with
saying that my family was
first-generation
immigrants here.
The services that were built
by the city and the state
weren't really meant for us.
We didn't have access
to it, because we
didn't have translation
services or cultural competency
within these institutions.
We made it work for ourselves.
I started off with the
story of my sister,
because it's really
important for me.
And that was what actually
got me started on this pathway
that I'm on now.
Thankfully, we're
all healthier than we
were when we were children.
But I think resonating with
people on a personal level
really does allow
you to help build
that bridge of a
mutually shared vision,
to ensure that you're
both fighting for--
doesn't have to be
100% the same fight,
but you have shared principles
that you can work together
with and ensure that you're
fighting alongside each other,
for each other.
I think that that's what
people tend to forget.
AUDIENCE: I want to
build on that question.
So I'm also an immigrant.
But I guess being white, I
don't have some of the issues
that other people
have to deal with.
But there is a possibility
if I do any activism
that, since I'm not a citizen,
I would put myself in jeopardy
of being able to stay here.
So what are recommendations
for if you want to contribute,
but you don't have
citizen status?
What are things you can
risk, and what are things
you definitely shouldn't risk?
MURAD AWAWDEH: So
I think that you
have to have that kind of
conversation with yourself.
I'm not an attorney, so I will
not give you any legal advice.
But what I would say is,
what level of activism
are you comfortable with?
Showing up to protest
is not illegal.
Anyone with status,
without status can do that.
You have the right
to be at a protest.
to raise your voice.
You have the right to be
on social media saying,
what's happening is wrong.
You have a right to
share your story.
You have a right to everything
else that a US citizen does,
with the exception of voting.
So I think exercising your
rights, as even a visa holder,
is very important.
But you have to take
care of yourself
and make sure that you're
not putting yourself
in precarious situations.
So if you're going
to a protest and you
know that people are going
to be getting arrested,
you might not want to
be standing next to them
when they do whatever they're
going to end up doing.
And that should go
out to everyone.
If you're going to a
protest and there's
going to be civil
disobedience, you
know that there will
be civil disobedience,
and you're in kind of
a different situation
where your status may
be in jeopardy, maybe
being around that situation
is not beneficial to you.
But you can always show
up to NYIC's events
where we coordinate
with the right agencies
to ensure that we're
doing everything
to ensure that everyone
who's there is protected
and not going to have any
issue for participating.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MURAD AWAWDEH: Hello.
AUDIENCE: I guess this is
kind of a broad question.
But in general, what do
non-profits need the most?
Is there one thing?
Is it money, or is it time?
Or is it specific?
MURAD AWAWDEH: I think
it's a little bit of both.
So it is, I would say,
more so volunteer time
with acquired skills.
So we're always
looking for volunteers.
If you go to our website,
which is on one of the slides,
www.NYIC.org, there is a
volunteer sign-up form,
which is very specific.
So we want to know as
much information of what
you can offer as possible
so that we don't waste
your time asking you
down the road, like, hey,
do you know how
to do translation,
do you know how to
do graphic design?
Our website looks like
it's going to fall,
can you help us with fixing
it up on the backend?
So that when you
are participating,
that's actual in-kind donation,
if you think about it.
So what you're doing
is providing nonprofits
with a resource
that they would have
to eventually pay for if you
don't provide your services.
So I would say the volunteering
part is more important.
But almost equally
important is the donations.
A lot of the time, folks tend
to forget that everything costs
money.
When you want to have a rally,
you have to pay for permits.
You have to pay for sound.
You have to pay for signs.
You have to pay for water.
If it's cold, you have
to pay for hand warmers.
So you just want to make
sure that you're taking care
of the people who are coming.
So you want to
make sure that you
have resources available to
make the purchases you need to.
Also, staff time-- if
you work at a nonprofit
or you don't, you should
know that, while folks
may think that we get paid
millions of dollars, we do not.
We're humbly paid.
So I think that
providing donations
to help build capacity
of organizations
is extremely important as well.
So I think volunteering
is important,
staying connected, and donating.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MURAD AWAWDEH: You're welcome.
Any final questions?
All right.
This has been great.
Thank you again for having me.
Thank you for coming out.
I'll be hanging out in
the back for a few minutes
if you guys have any questions.
Thank you again.
[APPLAUSE]